let's bring in fox news senior strategic
analyst retired general jack keane
general thanks for being here
your thoughts on this day
well it's certainly an astounding day
and in terms of what's taking place
before our eyes and and i think from uh
from the perspective of the military the
american people our soldiers you know
who participate in afghanistan it's also
a humiliating day
um and and very frustrating
there's been some serious
miscalculations made here
brett i mean just a few weeks ago the
president was claiming that the taliban
cannot take over the country the afghan
security forces are going to be able to
stand up against it and obviously what
what's unfolded before our eyes is quite
the opposite and there there are
reasonable explanations for why that is
the case why
why is the situation collapsing so
quickly and one of the intangibles
that's so difficult to measure by our
intelligence community or even our
military leaders
is
what would be the impact of taking
decisive air power away from the afghan
security forces who are used to having
u.s air power and u.s intelligence in
support of them
and they've always with that air power
been able to stop taliban offensives in
the past if we pull that out
what is the impact of that well that's a
subjective evaluation to be sure and
even the military people didn't know
what that impact would have on the
security forces and you can see it
right before our eyes it's not the only
reason but it's the primary reason this
is a ground force that's used to having
very capable u.s
air support when there's an offensive
taking place and they don't have it now
they're coming from other countries but
they call it over the horizon but listen
eight hours to get to the target brett
they can't stay that long when you're
dealing with an offensive you have to
have enduring consistent air power
staying on the target continuously for
hours and that makes the enemy go away
and we need ground coordinators to make
that air power general effect there are
a lot of people who say that's part of
the reason this is a long time this is
almost two decades on the ground and i
did many stories on in afghanistan about
the afghan training and the efforts to
get that force up and running the the
money that was spent the equipment that
was sent to them and the afghan forces
number
a significant number and they have good
equipment but yet
we're saying that they can't defend
themselves we're seeing these cities
fall one after another herat ghazni
kandahar this afternoon and maybe kabul
although there's some thought that maybe
they're not going to do the big fight in
kabul and just wait to negotiate
yes certainly i mean
and that's a valid point to make
we've been there 20 years we're there
because we're involved in a
multi-generational war against radical
islam that doesn't have an end date that
i'm aware of but certainly we have
national leaders that have determined
that as to the forces themselves the
afghan security forces listen we've
always had problems with it we've never
said
that this is a highly capable force that
i'm that i'm aware of but nonetheless we
believe we were training to be effective
enough
with the enablers provided to them
to be able to deal with the taliban we
knew full well they couldn't defeat the
taliban i mean we didn't have enough
forces there to do that ourselves uh
when we were there so but we knew for a
fact that the taliban didn't have the
capability to take the country over
either and it was stalemated and that's
why people were seeking you know a
political solution to what appeared to
be
somewhat of an intractable problem for
both sides that that wasn't the answer
either obviously yeah you know uh
general you serve in the vietnam war
you're a ranger paratrooper uh platoon
leader leader company commander
today
that image of vietnam came up in the
questioning of admiral john kirby take a
listen
are you going to avoid
a parallel with the fall of saigon
what this is going to look like is what
it is we're not walking away from our
commitments to the afghan forces we're
not completely eliminating our
diplomatic presence on the ground we're
still going to have diplomats there
nobody is abandoning afghanistan it's
not walking away from it
it's doing the right thing at the right
time to protect our people
your thoughts on the comparison the
contrasts and where we are today
well certainly it is a reason for a
comparison certainly um
we did lose political uh support and
resolve for the war in vietnam which
finally you know the the congress
terminated any financial support so we
can no longer provide air power to
support uh the ground forces which were
the south vietnamese and what what we're
seeing
right before our eyes today happened
then the north vietnamese rolled it up
very quickly
i i was just it was like a gut punch you
know for a platoon leader company
commander to see an ending like that um
i really held my uh my senior military
leaders and and somewhat in contempt to
be frank about it they're having a wrong
strategy for three years from 65 to 68
which protracted the war and for my
national leaders not having the stomach
the stand up to what was taking place
and and here we we've made similar
miscalculations in my in my mind
listen
we have five places brett and i think we
have evolved over the global war on
terror we've gotten more sophisticated
about it there's 40 to 50 movements out
there we're only involved in five
syria iraq yemen east africa and
afghanistan was one of them this is
where u.s troops are involved for one
reason only because all five of those
places we believe
that the radicals there have aspirations
to attack the american people i only
have a few seconds
but let me just ask and it's a modest
force for all of that and it seems to me
to be a prudent decision and how you're
going to secure the american people just
a few seconds do you think the trump
administration would do something
different in exiting this than the biden
administration has done
well i'm not even convinced that
president trump would eventually have
exited it even though it obviously was
part of his campaign but i mean i can't
do anything but speculate about that
i i don't know for sure uh listen i i do
know when you made the decision to leave
brett there should have been a lot of
other
issues on the table what are we going to
do to prevent the taliban from taking
over because you can't convince me to
president biden
has any interest in the taliban running
afghanistan with all the geopolitical uh
significance that has in dealing with
our adversaries and our allies certainly
that's not on his agenda so why what was
the thoughts in the process how do we
prevent that from happening
does
31 august really make sense and right
how are we going to apportion the
resources i don't know if those
questions really got answered
or even asked for that matter because
this is a huge miscalculation yeah and
there's no sense the taliban wants
international recognition uh from the un
or anybody else uh general jack keane we
appreciate your analysis always
yeah great talking to brett